I don't mind money money per se doesn't
bother me it's money I just hope it's
money made the right way creating real
value as opposed to creating that stuff
dreams are made on and that you know if
people make lots of money creating a you
know a new device to revolutionize use
of energy well that and they make a lot
of money a billion bucks I think that
we're all better off for it if someone
is able to orchestrate a manipulative
trading of one-off derivatives that no
one can understand so they can rip off
some of their clients that make a
billion bucks or they can aid and abet
fraud that that Enron commits but still
get off because of a limited definition
of who's an aider and abetter I don't I
think that's bad so the problem I see is
that it starts way before where we are
now it starts probably by the time
you're about ten years old in terms of
what that ethical core is and after that
and and and the backbone so knowledge of
ethics and backbone by about age of ten
and after that it gets very hard to
change people's orientation for the
better but it can get worse if you're
immersed in people and competing with
people who don't play by the same rules
as you do that may not be an answer but
that's the way I feel about